In the midst of the debate on gun violence,
gun rights and gun control; the largest group
of victims is being overlooked.
Sixty-four percent of gun victims aren't at
schools, or on rampages.
Instead, a study in 2012 found most gun violence
victims, are the same one who pulls the trigger.
Almost two-thirds of all gun deaths in the
U.S. are from suicides; according to this
study in the Annual Review of Public Health,
and of those, most are white males.
Homicide rates get a lot of media coverage,
but due to the stigma around it suicide does
not.
According to the CDC, in 1997, suicide was
the eighth leading cause of the death in the
United States overall.
And now, according to this new study, white
males are eight times more likely to kill
themselves with a gun than be killed by someone
using a gun.
Surprisingly, the data shows white people
commit 70 percent of ALL suicides; far more
than Hispanics or African-Americans.
Suicide is among the top ten causes of death
for Latino males, but isn't in the top ten
for black men or for women of any race; and
most of the time, those suicides are with
a firearm.
Why someone would choose suicide is usually
heavily connected with their overall mental
health.
95 percent of all those who take their own
lives have a diagnosable psychiatric disorder,
according to Columbia University Doctor Victoria
Arango, and, she says, more than half of suicide
victims are clinically depressed.
Which means, most of these white men fall
into this category.
You might think "they're chock full of white
male privilege! what do they have to be depressed
about?!"
A study in the Journal of Racial and Ethnic
Health Disparities, found white men do have
fewer life stressors; they lack the social
support structure to properly deal with the
stress they do have.
And the long-term mishandling of stress can
lead to depression.
If it does, men are less likely to pursue
therapy, and will often live with depression
having never been diagnosed.
This research shows white men are more prone
to depression stemming from stressful life
events than black men or all women.
Although more research is needed on why that
is.
In a 1995 study in Progress in Brain Research,
looked at the brains of those who committed
suicide and compared them to brains of depressed
people who hadn't.
Even though both brains had lower levels of
serotonin activity, those depressed people
who'd contemplated suicide had different orbital
cortices than depressed people who hadn't.
Markedly in areas connected to executive function,
decision-making and behavioral inhibitions.
The researchers said most don't think of suicide
at all, while others think of it first, because
suicide victims often have trouble controlling
impulses.
Which brings us back to firearms.
Firearms facilitate impulsive actions.
Papers in the journals Crisis and Suicide
and Life-Threatening Behavior found suicides
are commonly impulse driven -- not elaborately
planned like in some television or film.
In fact according to their findings, 25 percent
of suicide attempters said they deliberated
for less than five minutes; in fact most (75
percent) debated less than an hour -- and
only 13 percent thought about it for more
than a day.
Because guns are point and click, it stands
to reason when depressed men, making an impulsive
action like suicide, they will reach for the
easiest method to carry it out.
The Harvard Health Policy Review reviewed
academic literature connecting suicide and
access to firearms; and found having a gun
slightly increases suicide risks and the journal
Trauma found rates of suicide in states with
the most gun ownership had twice the rate
of gun-involved suicide as the states with
the least gun ownership.
More guns means more gun-involved suicide,
by a lot.
On top of that, according to a Pew Research
Center study, men own three times the number
of guns, and white men own more than double
the number of blacks and three times more
than hispanics.
It would seem, the reason white men are eight
times more likely to commit suicide with a
gun is because they're depressed, have no
way to deal with it, have a gun in their home
and decided to do it in only a few minutes.
Study after study shows reducing access to
guns saves lives and reduces suicide rates,
and this is why.
If you need help call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline at 1 (800) 273-8255; and
reach out to friends, family.
If you'd like to know more about what time
of year people are more likely to commit suicide,
check out this video